échappée ben c'est beaucoup mieux parce
que j'ai encore la maladie donc moi là
et ils veulent pas l'enlever alors je
sais pas encore et je sais pas comment
je vais faire pour l'enlever et pourquoi
n'ont pas voulu enlever la balle passe
comme on dit là bas les loger dans son
thorax entre deux eaux et ça ils peuvent
pas le bouger si l'on veut même ils vont
faire les dégâts le font mieux que ça
reste là ça n'a pas bougé mais je vais
pas rester comme ça je pense que la
barre pour moi aussi je fais ça je ne
peux pas voilà en fait c'est là que j'ai
pris la balle hélas l'histoire s'est
fait jusque là bas alors c'est pas pour
dire que j'étais tout près j'étais vie
vraiment loin en plus il ya une balle
qui est passé peu de mes yeux je cherche
la balle par terre ce matin je découvre
ses salles dans la voiture là l'autre
balle est entrée alors j'allais avoir
deux balles et j'y crois toujours
il ya eu plusieurs tirs avec plusieurs
fusils à l'eau oui on aurait dit que
c'est un western mais ça faisait pas des
gros gros gros bout hier c'était bob
bobos comme si c'est un jeu mais ces
deux gamines qui ont couru comme des
malades je me dis mais qu'est ce
qu'elles sont a dit quand j'ai vu qu'ils
soient gardés par la gt voix et ces deux
là j'ai vu un anglais entre un petit
roman malade et puis l'autre qui
ripostaient mais je voyais pas l'autre
alors je ne vais pas dire cette équipe
et puis voilà du coup là je me retourne
pour rentrer chez moi je vois ne parle
pas c'est quoi de mes yeux après je
regarde je sens mon bras me faire
naviguer j'étais une balle je suis entré
chez moi après la police et puis le samu
et quand je reviens à mon frère me dit
qu'une balthus end je dis ouais j'ai
pris une balle et puis du coup la balle
entre la et des sorties sur mon bras et
il est rentré dans mon auto actions
cotées et puis voilà je suis là donc les
deux protagonistes avaient des fusils et
tiercé anglais mark août
je ne sais pas de quoi mais c'est
règlement de comptes il paraissait pour
une fête salle mais je sais pas pourquoi
mais c'est horriblement le cas pour une
femme
et puis voilà mon état pourquoi je sais
pas